with such a huge selection on Netflix
finding a good movie can be a daunting
task
that's why we've gone through the
Netflix lineup to find the best little
scene films available from horror to
comedy to action here are the best
Netflix Jim's you probably haven't seen
yet
the Wraith back in the Technicolor 80s
there was a wonderful movie called the
Wraith the idea a murdered street racer
returns from the grave to get revenge on
a bunch of street punks in an undead
muscle car as far as terrible but
awesome premises go this sits somewhere
near the top of the stack and yet in
spite of everything it's got going
against it
the Wraith actually works it's solid
b-movie material elevated to hidden gem
status by colorful characters
surprisingly good special effects and
fun dialogue the Wraith knows full well
what it is and it doesn't take itself
too seriously kill me three times Simon
Pegg is a modern cult megastar but this
hilarious crime thriller still managed
to fly under the radar on its 2014
release with a kinetic style reminiscent
of Guy Ritchie's good films kill me
three times follows three intertwine
stories of ordinary people driven to the
brink all of it linked by one man with a
very hitman mustache a Simon Pegg hitman
mustache at times brutal touching and
hilarious sometimes all at once you
won't find a more flat-out fun movie
than kill me three times creep who knew
a film with the cast of exactly two
people could be so enthralling yeah you
might groan at first if creep had a
downside it would be the decision to
make it in jerky handheld found footage
style but creep pulls it off and
beautifully at that in fact this may be
the first film since the Blair Witch
Project that couldn't have been filmed
any other way and arguably the first
good one creep switches seamlessly
between drama comedy and horror thanks
mostly to a near-perfect performance by
mumbly maniac mark Duplass whatever else
you take away from it there's no doubt
creep will give you well the creeps
Bronson back in 2008 before he was a
household name Tom Hardy starred in a
bizarre biopic called Bronson in real
life Charles Bronson whose real name was
Michael Peterson before he renamed
himself after the actor has spent more
than 40 years in prison and was dubbed
the most violent prisoner in Britain
even though he's never killed anyone
when Tom Hardy was first tapped to star
in the movie the real Bronson was less
than impressed
by the actor but after Hardy gained a
ton of weight and studied the way the
real-life criminal moved
Bronson changed his tune saying Tom
looks more like me than I look like me
if you were impressed by Bane and Mad
Max Rockatansky don't miss out on
Bronson it's got its weird moments but
the movie is insanity at its best
[Music]
ravenous there aren't a lot of movies
that'll make you question your dinner
but from the very first frame ravenous
turns rare steak into an entree to be
regarded with suspicion
starring Guy Pearce and Robert Carlyle
this 1999 gem plays like a horror movie
on the surface but does so with a heart
of comedic black gold while it begins as
a seemingly straightforward story of an
army captain assigned to the remote
Sierra Nevada mountains after the
mexican-american war
ravenous quickly moves into territory
that's hard to classify there's the
horror of cannibalism in the isolated
mountains the action of a spaghetti
western a fixed mattering of
tongue-in-cheek humor and a pulsing vein
of modern satire woven throughout all
that comes together into an extremely
entertaining offbeat movie experience
that you won't forget anytime soon
unfortunately the film's marketing send
people to theaters expecting a more
mainstream slapstick comedy not the
violent black humor they ended up
watching as a result ravenous was chewed
to pieces by critics and limped through
theaters earning a measly two million
dollars half of which came during its
opening weekend beyond the gates you
could probably get away with calling
this movie Jumanji - this time with
demons but that wouldn't be entirely
fair - beyond the gates a horror
thriller about two brothers who find a
VHS board game in their recently
deceased father's video store video
board games were a real weird thing in
the VCRs heyday so there's probably a
nostalgia element to beyond the gates if
you were one of the 30 or 40 people who
ever played one but for everyone else
the idea of a video that knows what
you're doing lends as much to the
fantasy element of the film as the
hellish repercussions the brothers
experience as they fall deeper into the
game hellish in this case is of course
totally literal the more of the brothers
play the more the game begins to bleed
into the real world turning their home
into the devil suburban dream house it's
a fun twisted film perfect for a rainy
night look who's back this low-key
German satire is both unexpected and
surprisingly hilarious look who's back
starts with Hitler waking up in a park
in modern Berlin still in uniform with
no idea how he got there the first
people he meets think he's a crazy hobo
the next ones think he's a method actor
doing a bit and before long Hitler's all
over the news is the next big German
comedian and the people love him in fact
it's less a satire on Hitler and more a
social commentary on modern-day Germany
as a whole on top of all that it's
pretty
funny look whose back is definitely a
weird combo but it's one that happens to
work extremely well uncanny
if you liked ex machina you'll be right
at home with uncanny a tight
claustrophobic movie about a brilliant
roboticist named David Cresson who
builds the perfect artificial
intelligence or is it when the robots
behavior grows more sinister the
programmer and his newfound girlfriend a
journalist on assignment to write about
crescents achievements find themselves
trapped in crescents lab with an
uncannily human creature who suddenly
become painfully unpredictable
beautifully shot and steeped in tension
you could cut with a bone saw uncanny is
a fantastic hidden sci-fi thriller with
incredible performances from everyone
involved you won't be able to look away
until the end the void in many ways the
John Carpenter horror thrillers of the
80s were a genre unto themselves movies
like the thing and Prince of Darkness
reveled in violence and body horror
without leaning on it as a pure shock
tactic and somehow in 2017 a small
sci-fi horror film slipped unnoticed
into that exclusive genre the void is a
throwback to those 80s Creature Features
in many ways from the practical monster
effects to the subdued foreboding
atmosphere but it also stands on its own
has a bloody good sci-fi creep fest
don't miss it thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]